all right I really like this story you
think of smart people in libraries
reading books but no it turns out
they're having sex and doing drugs I
knew it all right so a bunch of studies
have come out lately sort of proving
this concept that it's people that are
having sex doing drugs and doing some
other naughty stuff that are actually
the smart ones we've got some info for
you in a study published in personality
and individual differences researchers
looked at a sample of over 20,000 people
that said that's a good number they
found that people with high IQs went to
bed about 30 minutes later so they're
staying up each night that's later than
people of normal intelligence the higher
the IQ the later they tend to stay up a
study in 2010 found that people of high
IQs are much more likely to experiment
with psychoactive drugs than people with
low IQs a study in 2011 found that
people who scored high in IQ tests as
children were much more likely to
experiment with drugs and adulthood
another study in 2012 found that
intelligent children were more likely to
use weed amphetamines and mushrooms
later in life we got one more for you
researchers in the UK found that
students studying at universities such
as Oxford and Cambridge spent more money
on sex toys than at other universities
other research found that the more
prestigious the University the more
students were having sex these studies
have sparked speculation that high
intelligence might be correlated with an
increased sex drive okay so you know we
do a lot about sex and drugs here I'm
not pushing sex and drugs anyone but I
do think there's something interesting
here something about perhaps that
experimentation is more important than
sitting at a book and learning
everything so is that the main takeaway
here that living and trying things out
is more important sure Noah get me a
takeaway but again 20,000 people yes
it's a large number but it's also like a
city block in Manhattan you know we're
not like a huge amount of the population
but I mean I'm I'm a night owl so I have
a high IQ yeah and I mean when you're up
late at night yeah that's when the brain
also starts to go or you're on the
Facebook you know and I mean hey it's
nighttime you're you're horny yes
there's the second one in or like your
brains constantly going if you're so
intelligent that
- maybe simmer down with some some drugs
yeah Jacqueline I know you're you're
pretty bright that's why we bring you
out here but you you don't do drugs
right no like psychoactive drugs like no
I honestly haven't but I've always been
you know curious about it so maybe I
just haven't been in the right place
right time yet right um but as far as
sleeping thing thirty minutes man I I
stay up way past most people like 4:00
or 5:00 a.m. is like going to bed early
for me so I must be like brilliant but
yeah I mean as far as like the sex and
drugs I think that like people who are
more intelligent might also tend to be
more open-minded and that lends itself
to trying new things right so that's
what I mean that there's just this if
you have the spirit in you of
experimentation you might it just moves
your mind I've done these things I've
smoked weed I've done mushrooms like I
don't want those doors open any more I
open those doors people always say to me
like oh you want to do some mushrooms
I'm like I don't need to if anything I
could call some of those doors at this
point I don't need to open them anymore
but I and what I think is interesting
about this is we always have this debate
about politicians and you know just this
week they were they found out that Jeb
Bush smoked weed and people were
freaking out and we know that Obama
smoked weed and probably did more than
that and I think it's so silly because
aren't you supposed to try some isn't
that what life is about trying some of
this stuff not being addicted to sex or
drugs or whatever it is but just trying
it and then learning from the experience
with three or diet a ribbon no but
really isn't that the point of the whole
damn yeah yeah
absolutely and I feel bad because a lot
of people look at drugs Sunday to see
you know these drug addicts he's like
really scary looking people who were
like on the verge of death you know and
just you know horrible lifestyles and
they think that that is the face of
anyone who uses drugs yeah and then that
stereotypes which is just not the case
because experimenting with something is
very different than developing an
unhealthy addiction yeah so there's that
if you uh if you guys were around
someone that was only book smart really
knew and I'm sure we all have these type
of friends that just know everything
right they read a ton they got all the
papers they read a lot of books but they
haven't experienced those things doesn't
that show why their brain
I can't get to some other level I
disagree with it because I was gonna say
also there's nothing wrong with just
sitting down and reading a great book
and using your imagination and going
into the story and I sound like a
fifth-grade teacher but you know I don't
necessarily think you need to do drugs
or get high to be able to experience
life you know you want to do it whatever
fine that's your choice but if you don't
I just I guess I agree with that but I
guess it to me it's more about the
choice the choice that you're putting on
yourself to not experience something I
suppose says something about your
intelligence maybe I don't know I'm not
totally sold maybe there maybe the books
they're reading or about the harm that
drugs do you know yeah I mean this is
your brain on drugs this is your brain
on drugs
there you go anyway are you doing drugs
are you having lots of sex drugs are bad
how dumb are you let us know in the
comments right down below
[Music]